always been resistant to being like the
chubby friend or this or that like I
just I've said no to things like that
and I waited until I could be you know
this person on Yellowjackets who has two
love interests I tried to be as thin as
I could I wore a lot of makeup all the
time I was like is this it is this it
and I keep getting reinforced with the
idea like no that's not quite it you're
still not quite what we're looking for
at a certain point I was like okay so I
give up so I may take it early 15. yeah
I think I'm just normal like I think
people are like hang on a minute she she
looks like me but I think it's
refreshing I think it's nice for people
to say